foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's get some recording going
gotta get to the right one here
and we are going to record to the clock
recording in progress
all right let's go ahead and open up the
doors to our Zoom room here on daily
with Doc zoom.com
welcome everybody welcome welcome
welcome my name is Becca dukes and I'm
so excited to see so many people waiting
in the waiting room as we are getting
ready to share empowering information
that allows you to be your own authority
because you have information
to add to what's already being fed to
you as far as how to obtain or maintain
Health now we're into the Wellness side
of Health we're not into Sick management
we want to provide information that can
be used as a resource for families
individuals communities the world
with complete Wellness folks
so it's not too late even if you feel
like you are death warmed over it's not
too late to be able to make positive
changes in your life in your
intake of food and specifically
nutrition through supplementation
because our food is null and void of the
nutrition that our bodies need to do
more than just barely survive
well we're not in the barely surviving
stage of Wellness we're into allowing
people to be able to have the
opportunity to thrive now the content of
this program is to provide educational
information only it is not to take the
place of your primary care physician our
products are not to diagnose treat
prevent cure any diseases but folks when
you give your body quality
supplementation notice I mentioned
quality
supplementation that is in a form that
the body can actually absorb
not just push through the system and
make you say feel good because oh I'm
taking this this and this but just
because you're taking something doesn't
mean that it's in a form that the body
can actually absorb
and just because you're taking something
doesn't mean that your digestive system
is in a state that you would be able to
absorb and that's what this program is
here for is to provide that information
to help you obtain Optimal Health
through thorough and
just as complete as we possibly can in
an hour
information
that just arms you and gives you more in
your toolbox of what you can actually do
but it's more than just taking the
information it's taking action
so we are doing a call to action for
everybody who this message is falling on
the ears of to take control of your own
health take action listen closely
because the information you're going to
hear today is not something that you're
going to hear probably in any big
building with a lot of white coats okay
even if well scrubs let's just use
scrubs because they're in all different
colors now
but folks
this program has been brought together
by dailywitdoc.com and it is because of
the Transformations that I have felt
that my self personally the
Transformations that I have been able to
see as I'm helping other people through
this journey to Wellness
and it's all because of the doc that we
have hosted on this program Dr Joel
Wallach and his research and his
teachings and his influence into the
formulas
that we find as not just a supplement
but a solution
so without further Ado it is with great
honor to be able to introduce to you and
bring to you Monday through Friday from
12 to 12 50 pm
Pacific time
somebody who not only is a doctor of
natural medicine
but before he got to that doctor of
natural medicine he had
around the world
three degrees
and pathology pulse Doctorate Degrees in
pathology he was a veterinarian big and
small he was a pathology student and
worked his way through college in the
Pathology Lab looking at so many
different parameters
of bodies
now human bodies animal bodies were all
created
and to take his passion that he found in
agriculture and plants and to see how
they react within the body
because he learned at a very young age
that when he changed what he was eating
his behavior changed things that he
didn't have control over changed because
of what he was putting in his body
so Dr Wallach thank you so much for
joining us here on daily with Doc I know
you've got some great information to
share with us what do you have for us
today
well thank you so much Rebecca you and
your team
[Music]
and I apologize to everybody we've been
having some technical difficulty with
internet
there's some conclusions that you would
freaking everybody out okay
I'm sorry
so I'm going to turn off your video Dr
Wallach that way we can hear you better
without any delays I'm going to turn
mine off as well and let's let them have
it without our cameras so they can focus
on the message
okay can you hear me now
yes we can hear you okay so we're gonna
go back to Adam okay
of
um and so we're talking about more than
three thousand years ago he lived me
930. Noah lived me
950. uh when you have let's see here
Methuselah he lived me 969.
um Jared lived me 962.
and you know I can go on and on and on
but you get the idea here okay and that
makes lived to be 777. and they lived it
was what was called the land flowing of
milk and honey
and in Israel today which was the land
flowing of milk and honey biblical time
in the Old Testament
Israel the life expectancy is 83 in
Egypt
their next door neighbor just like
Canada is our next door neighbor their
next door neighbor Egypt their life
expectancy 71 so the Israelis live 12
years longer than the Egyptians okay
which is kind of a small replication
what happened three thousand years ago
all right now
um should kind of keep pursuing this
um I looked at in the 20th century okay
one of the more famous
um uh pastors Christian pastors Billy
Graham lived to be 99 close to 100. not
900 they're close to 100. okay and then
a rabbi a famous Rabbi the 20th century
uh Rabbi Arnold um to hear Jacob Wolfe
live to be 84. all right and that's kind
of good when you compare to all the
other people who you know because their
life expectancies the United States is
75.
um Canada is 84. why are they 84 because
they have the land flowing of milk and
honey what yeah they are big they have
all these mountains and volcanoes and
they have the the land flowing with milk
and honey which is the
um glacial
milk it's not cow's milk it was the land
flowing with milk and honey which
everybody tries to explain it with
through cow's milk and goat's milk and
camel milk and all that kind of stuff no
it was glacial milk coming down from the
mountains which is there's many of in
Israel okay and so when you start
looking at that and let's look at a
little more information here
um
I mean look at Hawaii one of our 50
States United States again their life
expectancy is 80.9 they have five active
volcanoes
in Mississippi that have one dead
volcano their life expectancy 74.4 from
six
um let's see here
um just a little more than a half a year
less than the average American because
they don't have enough minerals okay the
land flow of milk and honey was flown
with glacial milk chapter 10 of my book
rare earth wind cures chapter 10 where
it was this book where Earth's been
appears in this book is flying out the
door we sold five cases yesterday we had
um even Amazon ordered I don't know how
many books today from us of the rare
earth wind chairs they aren't a bunch of
them because people are realizing the
information how to add 25 to 50 healthy
years to your life lies in our diet in
our settlement program nutritional
Metals do not occur in the uniform blank
around the coast of the earth they occur
in veins like gold and silver
okay
plans do not make minerals what you just
kind of you cannot eat well the ones who
are in the most danger are vegetarians
because plants do not make minerals
plants make vitamins amino acids and
fatty acids or carbon compounds you
learned that in fourth grade
that the plants the green leafy you know
Green Leaves they get the thank you
they get the
um the carbon monoxide out of the air
and turn them into carbon compounds of
vitamins amino acids and fatty acids but
they have to get the middle so the soil
and and plants really need three
elements NPK we need 60 minerals six
zero minerals okay and the only way
you're going to get a guaranteed you're
going to get them is a supplement with
them okay now
no
in the Old Testament
in the Old Testament there's a hundred
references to the land flowing of milk
and honey the Old Testament
sorry about this folks we are having
some technical difficulties with Dr
wallach's camera with his internet
um we do apologize I don't know if he's
going to jump back on here we've been
working on uh solutions for this so if
you could just bear with me one minute
he's back he just needs to unmute
okay Dr Wallach could you unmute please
thank you
all right Rebecca's gonna see if she can
get Doc's camera and stuff going so bear
with us please I'm sorry for this
interruption in the show
just bear with us please
um
it's been an interesting morning trying
to get it working so uh Nancy to answer
your question the audio will not be
better on the phone bear with us please
actually while we're waiting for uh
Rebecca to get things figured out
um Maryland had an interesting question
that she was going to ask so we can fill
the space with that question and I will
answer her questions
um so Marilyn if you want to unmute and
ask your question that would be great
okay fantastic hi everybody
um I have had individuals say that
sometimes they feel the products
um are too sweet and they specifically
say Beyond teeny tangerine and the
osteofex
now what's interesting is the label says
no sugars so if you can give me
um options for them and how to make it
less sweet and also why it might be
tasting sweet
okay
I get this question all the time
and a lot of times it's they're not
adding enough water
some people use an eight ounce glass of
water for the full scoop or two scoop
you know or as half a scoop of each and
that's just not enough water so 16 to 14
24 ounces is a good amount of water
um some people are very sensitive to
sweet
and it and Dr wallach's holding up a
bottle of water so I'm just going to
finish answering this question then
we'll see what we got going on
um and then sometimes
if you add plant derived minerals like
one ounce to it
that will cut the sweet and other times
if people don't have that then I
recommend unsweetened cranberry juice
and you just add it to taste until it
cuts the sweet
what is making what is making it so
sweet is it is it just a fruitful Foods
added or do you interrupt here it's
usually because it's too much but Dr
Wallach is back so we're gonna let him
finish answering that question answer
that question
okay I'm on you can hear me now right
yes sir okay
I have to appreciate
that
when you ask osteoporosis of the skull
it's affecting the tongue the ninth
Trail on Earth gospel pharyngeal nerve
and the twelve crane nerve
it affects your taste so if everything
tastes sweet to you it could be the
ninth criminal nerve in the 12th cranial
nerve being squeezed by your skull and
you have osteoporosis of the skull it's
a pathological issue it's not what
you're eating is your brain is
interpreting things incorrectly because
it's being squeezed by the skull when
you have osteoporosis of the skull okay
and so it's a giveaway well I don't have
any sugar but everything tastes sweet
well that's because your skull is
squeezing the ninth Tree on the Earth's
glossopharyngeal nerve which is the
tongue in your throat and the 12th
cranial nerve okay which also has
something to do with taste including
sweet and sour okay so that's a clue
okay and of course we have this new
um
book coming out here okay there's a flip
chart and it's one of these things that
goes on your computers
and so hopefully by the end of this
month it'll be the hands the attorneys
and it's going to be 90 for life crusade
to save the world and Humanity okay and
right now there's 65 pages in there I
suspect with the references and a few
more pictures and things like that it's
going to be more like 75 Pages kind of
thing and it's a presentation thing and
it's got at least a dozen famous people
attorneys lawyers
um people who are people who are
athletes professional athletes yeah
Olympic athletes we have people who are
um professional recording artists
uh
this is a recurring person and also
people who are in the government okay
we're talking about very high-end
government people okay and journalists
and and so forth we're talking about
athletes who are champions and and so
forth we have women Champions we have
men Champions and stuff so we kept the
girls involved as well okay and
this is going to help people understand
what they have to do to add 25 to 50
Health years of your life that's why I
started out you know again with the life
expectancy between the 20th century
pastors and rabbis and stuff like that
because
it's 800 years shorter than they were
back in the days of the Old Testament
no I was at well in the Old Testament
they lived in the land flowing milk and
honey which was what is now Israel all
of the all of the stuff coming down from
the mountains which we now call glacial
milk back then they were just calling it
the land flowing with milk and honey
because the water coming down from the
mountains looked white because of all
the rock dust in the creeks and the
streams and so forth made it look like
milk
and um it just they just figured that
the good Lord gave us milk which the
good Lord did give us milk but it's it's
not cow's milk it's glacial milk
everybody needs to get a hold of that
book you want to hold that one up again
Becca the book we're in cures I mean oh
well either doc I'm sorry
it's not goat milk either there
is that goat's milk okay is that Camel's
milk goat's milk cow's milk it's glacial
milk and so once you realize it's the
minerals and we spent six months before
we started the youngevity business
looking around where we're going to do
something different why were we going to
be different than everybody else and
then we discovered it that the people
including the hunzas whose their life
expectancy is 120 in our life expectancy
75 okay and it's 45 years longer they
lived in us on the average
so what is it well it's all the glaciers
that they live under and we had some
places like that called bottomland okay
and we didn't call it glacial milk but
in bottomland all that white stuff
coming down from the mountains and the
rivers in the spring when the snow would
all melt would go in the fields and when
the water would dissipate from the
floods over a couple of weeks it left
anywhere from a half inch to a couple
inches of the silt on the fields the
farmer ground plowed in they love
bottomland because they didn't have to
fertilize it they didn't have to buy
fertilizer because they were getting the
fertilizer naturally okay from the
bottomland floods
and so once we dammed up the rivers to
make electricity hydroelectricity and
stopped all the flooding and most of the
people who drive in the streets and
stuff like that oh it's great we don't
have to worry about floods anymore but
the farmers who had bottomlands they got
cheated
out of their free fertilizer and the
plants that they grew there are no
longer plants to contain 75 minerals and
now they're just plants that have maybe
three to five to eight to ten minerals
and so that's why you have to supplement
you cannot get everything you need just
by eating well that's why the life
expectancy of a billionaires is only
66.7 and that's why we have
the CD okay it's called Dr wallach's oh
no let me pack up it's called there's a
new Bull in town this one the new Bull
in town There's freeze TDS in here
there's a new Bull in town okay and this
CD there you go
um actually
teaches you why you need to supplement
we got a rebound our score strength with
100 nutrients in it 75 which are
minerals your plant minerals 75 plant
minerals
Red Bull only has one magnesium so the
first CD is dead athletes don't lie just
like Dead Doctors Don't Lie dead
athletes Don't Lie the second seed is
exercise of supplementation of suicide
that's why so many professional athletes
and Olympic athletes don't do well
they're a life expectancy in America
it's
57.6 you got to be kidding me but they
exercise your Olympic athletes you're
professional athletes they eat well yes
but they don't supplement because
somebody tells them just say well you
don't need who is it oh it's the medical
doctors they say well you don't need
vitamins and minerals because when
you're sweating you're not just sweating
out water you're sweating out of soup of
all your nutrients and if you're not
perfect
um let's see replacing them okay or I
like to prevent so you want to build up
a nice store of all these minerals and
your bones and your cartilage and your
tissues okay and so if you have to miss
a couple meals you're still going to get
all your minerals you need just walk
down the street
and if you're exercising no I walk three
miles a day
I only weigh 142 pounds but I take
enough supplements for 250 to 300 pound
person
and I have been doing this for over
what 75 years hello okay and so this is
why
if you do these things you will gain 25
to 50 healthy years in in longevity be
with your your relatives your loved ones
uh I just get breathless when I think of
what you can do for your family by
giving them this information getting
them started on these programs
and if they don't want to do it you've
done your best keep giving it to them
for their birthday birthdays or
anniversaries or their holidays and so
forth you just keep giving it to them
and every once in a while they may take
some but if you stop giving it to them
they're not going to get it okay and you
know if you are a business person with
youngevity you can actually write that
off you know it's giving giving away
samples which is what you're doing okay
so you get a tax break there okay and so
it's not like you're just throwing money
away you need to take care of the people
you love you need to take care of your
neighbors your church mates your
workmates your family
and
it will pay off because people start
calling you the salt of the earth well
it sounds bad causes high blood pressure
no salt is required for every cell in
your body and when you do something good
back in the old days they knew that and
they said in the old days you're the
salts of the earth look that up okay
look that up what does that mean you're
the salt of the earth that means you're
an angel that means you're doing
something good for your community your
family your neighborhood the world when
you're the salt of the earth if salt was
bad when you say stuff like that
okay and so with all that said we do
have the season of song from Australia
which has I don't know 28 minerals in it
from the oceans around Australia and
then we have the Himalayan salt and the
life expectancy of the himalayans who
use
was it what is it they use for bread
they use millet flour yes begins with an
M millet they do not use wheat or oats
for bread they use millet and then they
have goats for milk and meat and then
they drink and they irrigate with their
glacial milk which has 75 minerals in it
that's why they live to be 120. they're
living in the land flowing with milk and
honey okay and so we follow their
examples that's why we chose this system
we picked them this is who we want to
live like we want to live to be 120 in a
healthful way many of them live to be
130 140 150
right and so we have work to do to get
everybody going in the right direction
here if you're living on fast foods and
soft drinks
um you know all the colas and ups and
all that kind of stuff and carbonated
water you're doomed
you're um the emergency room doctors
their life expectancy in America
emergency room doctors in America their
life expectancy 58.7
because they listen to themselves
they're just eating well this would be
58.7 this is published every year
because they try to see if it's getting
better or worse every year in medical
journals it's bullish it's not something
it's just being said this is published
in medical journals very well documented
okay and again Canada their life
expectancy is 84. ours is 75. they live
nine years longer than those why because
the land flowing is milk and honey they
have more volcanoes that are active than
we have and they have all this glacial
milk coming down into their Farm fields
which is their bottom land okay and they
don't use as much as your electricity as
we do so they're still plowing in all
those Metals into the fields and so
that's why they live nine years longer
than us
okay this is not difficult you just put
dirt in your car and say I don't have to
put it all in my car there's probably
oil in that dirt from Texas I save a lot
of money by putting dirt from Texas in
there instead of oil
you don't do that you you check the air
in your tires you check the oil in your
car you make sure you have plenty of
coolants in the radiator and all that
kind of stuff you don't do that for
yourself you don't check yourself out
every day like you do your car
take care of yourself take the good
stuff you need stay away from the bad
stuff so we get you in trouble and
you'll add 25 to 50 healthier is your
life you know I was just 84 this last
weekend on Sunday
and most people think I'm in my 50s when
they look at my energy and you know what
I look like I don't look like I'm 84.
okay I can still just get out with the
best of them and when it comes to uh I I
walk three miles a day and as I'm
walking I do push-ups on a walker so I
don't fall down or break a bone okay I
don't have any osteoporosis or anything
like that but I have a little injury
from a from a um thing up in Canada
where I fell in a construction ditch and
got punctured in many places with rebar
almost died but anyway the thing is
I'm 84 and I can still walk three miles
a day I can do it all at once but I
don't I walk them out and I do an hour
of work of worse and worth of work and
then I um do another mild than I do
another hour's worth of work and then I
do another mile then after my two hours
of radio and zoom with Rebecca I do
another mile okay and then I still do a
lot of walking because we have so many
things to do and we live on a pretty
sizable property and
it's one of those things where you know
you had to kick out the bad guys meaning
coyotes and and wolves and welcome the
deer
I haven't seen any wolves yet Dr Wallach
I think there's a bomb bat upstairs you
never know
but you know your wife Milan has the
Kindest Heart all the animals love to
come and visit
and that just that that says something
Dr Wallach
and I was so proud of you at contact in
the desert I mean that was on a big
Resort where we had things going on
throughout the whole campus of the
resort and you were just right there in
Step not missing a beat not even
complaining in 100 degree weather you
did so fantastic at 84 years old and
just kept that smile and that that love
for people I it was so inspiring
to drink rebound
yeah we got we had we had our rebound
that's for sure we definitely had our
rebound
well the doctor well like we've got a
few questions here and folks if you're
here live with us on Zoom thank you so
much for your patience even if you're
out not live with us and watching the
live streams we thank you for your
patience as we're working through some
technical difficulties uh technology is
absolutely fabulous when it works right
yeah
they have patience
that's right
I I'm so glad that I'm not a doctor Dr
Wallach and I have more patience than I
know what to do with and I guess God
blesses us whatever we need it that's
for sure
but let's go ahead and get you some
questions Dr Wallach
and folks if you're here with us and you
have a question please raise your hand
we will be getting to those questions in
the order that they were asked and the
first one is going out to YouTube an
angel is writing in about a 30 year old
man five foot eleven
155 pounds
he has a herniated herniated disc
Lupus anticoagulant
faint eye floaters
varicose veins
raynotts the poor circulation in the
feet
and he's currently gluten free which he
just became gluten-free he's on the
ultimate selenium the glucogel and the
ultimate daily classic but Dr Wallach
what would you recommend for a full
protocol for this young man he's too
young to have all this stuff going on
okay well none of this stuff has to do
with aging it's all due to nutritional
deficiencies now lupus doctors would
tell you having autoimmune disease your
body's attacking itself
but it has to do with gluten because
your intestines are dead when you have
Lupus you can't absorb nutrition
efficiently okay so that's got to get
and he's done that he says he's getting
gluten-free so it's gluten-free and
buckwheat free okay
and then
no fried foods no processed Meats no
oils no glutens and we put around oats
no sugar no carbonated drinks you know
the diet drinks got to go and and the
carbon of water has to go and then his
body weight he said 155
hard packs per month that's what I do
and take a full dose of everything twice
a day use two bottles of MSM so you take
three at breakfast free at lunch and
three dinner time they're gonna help
support and promote mange repair of
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue discs between every bone makes
them both self including that includes
his bone marrow which is he needs for
his
um his um white blood cells to support
his immune system and also uh will help
his skin I also want him to have our
synaptive he can take three of those
twice a day which I do I want him to
take our I-26 take three doses a day of
that that's going to help him rebuild
his brain and his white matter in the
brain and spinal cord and um for the
floaters I want them to have our occult
they could take three of those twice a
day and then for the skin he needs the
healthy brain and heart attack is that
right no he needs the
hairs for the nails
you can take three of those twice a day
I do that okay I only weigh 142. and
then for veins and blood pressure and
all that kind of stuff he needs the
ultimate daily classic tablets take
through those twice a day and he's gonna
be a new man but don't cold turkey off
of any medication if he has high blood
pressure I didn't hear that mentioned if
he had have a pressure
um and he needs to
standards medication but as the blood
pressure drops you can slowly reduce the
medication if you get a sleep an hour
after dinner that's called
um reactive hypoglycemia he does need
the sweet ease but when he has when
people have Lupus they can't absorb
anything so even if they're
supplementing okay they're eating gluten
it's all going out into the septic tank
so all the bugs in the septic tank are
happy but the guy's not happy but we can
get rid of everything he's complaining
about including lupus it is not
autoimmune disease body is not attacking
itself it's a combination of gluten
problems and secondary nutritional
deficiencies now if he wants to he can
speed things up by taking our ultimate
enzymes our gallbladder bottle I do that
I take two of those at the beginning of
each meal okay and that helps you absorb
all the nutrition including essential
fatty acids which prevents strokes and
blood clots and all that kind of stuff
so that's a lot but what he's got okay
these things can kill him the lupus can
kill him okay and the veins being in
trouble and kill him with blood clots
and all kind of stuff okay and the disc
between the vertebrae uh is it really
the disc between vertebrae or is it
osteoporosis of the skull okay so you
really should get the book and the CD
set osteoporosis of the skull cell in
your head okay and then call us in two
weeks and four weeks in six weeks
because he is going to have a great
story this is this is very common this
is a constant picture we see you and I
and the ladies see every day you know we
see thousands of people from 80
countries every day and what this guy's
just described we see all the time okay
and so we know we get the results okay
we just had such a great testimony a day
or so ago
yeah yesterday
yeah yesterday yeah so
they were gone in a couple of months
the herniated disc Dr Wallach there is a
there's an external device that you
recommend that goes beyond nutrition
and I use it
and I hang upside down
it feels good
yeah the inversion table so I know when
I just when I first started I had heard
you mention getting an inversion table
and I gotten on the pig pack plus and so
I got the inversion table I was going
through compression
decompression therapies three times a
week Dr Wallach and it hurts so bad it
felt good
but then I feel
afterwards
I still hurt
and I can do the inversion table here at
home it costs a fraction of the money
um and and it feels it feels better and
it's using my own Gravity the own my own
weight to be able to pull things apart
let things settle as you get upside down
and you're gently rotating going up and
down up and down I know that was a big
part of what I think helped me but it
was the nutrition that was key Dr
Wallach
well yeah you have to have the nutrition
otherwise you're not going to get the
response from your exercises or whatever
it is you're doing okay you need to bend
from the from that by getting the
nutrition it's kind of like if you run
your car without oil and you run your
car without airing the tires you run
your car without coolant you're not
going to run very far
no you're not going to run very far at
all and there's a story that I know
about Dr Wallach where even somebody
that had severe muscle atrophy
has been able to take the nutrition
and you would never know it now
not at all and has been able to build
lots of lots of great muscle and just
create a body through nutrition and
nothing artificial not none of those
hormones none of the testosterone none
of the
extra what would you what did you say no
surgery
yeah no surgeries
no surgeries so you can do a lot when
you give your or your body can do a lot
when you give it what it's really
needing
well Dr Wallach let's go to our first
hand up and Deborah Deborah go ahead and
unmute yourself and then we'll get to TC
hello Dr Wallach hello everyone
um uh my question is I have a 54 year
old female
that is a hundred and sixty pounds she's
five feet five inches
and she has been diagnosed with breast
cancer she's had a bilateral mastectomy
and she's struggling with this whole
concept that cholesterol does not cause
heart attacks so she's on cholesterol
lowering medication
okay well cholesterol learning
medications is her biggest enemy at this
point
cholesterol medication is her biggest
enemy at this point
cholesterol lowering medication is enemy
to for her at this point okay do I have
to say it again okay no all right uh
cholesterol makes up 25 of your brain
weight 25 percent of your spinal cord
weight and it's called myelin it's the
white matter of the brain also is the
covering for all the nerves in your body
is cholesterol makes up
95 of estrogen and 95
testosterone cholesterol is extremely
important and she's going to wind up
with Alzheimer's disease she'll wind up
with um things like um Ms Guillain-Barre
syndrome which is ms's spinal cord she
can wind up with his new one FTD frontal
temporal dementia
um she wound up if she has if she has
trimmers with Parkinson's disease this
is all just simple deficiencies of
cholesterol cholesterol did not block
your arteries that was a big mistake
they made over 100 years ago about 120
years ago made a big big mistake I've
seen cholesterol is what was blocking
arteries that was not true then it's not
true now okay but they've killed more
people with that instruction than all
the wars that we've died in fighting to
save America okay you need cholesterol
okay and so
um we have I-26 you need the I-26
uh three servings a day okay that's to
rebuild her white matter in her brain
and spinal cord and all her nerves and
everything
she needs two of the health abandoned
heart packs per month because she weighs
what do we say 155 160. once 150 or 160
160. yeah okay and so
um she needs a uh two healthy brand hard
packs fold over something twice a day
she needs two
um of the bottles of medicine she take
three breakfasts three laundry dinner
time but again that's going to rebuild
cartilage and ligaments and tendons and
bone marrow so you can have white blood
cells and red blood cells and platelets
and all that kind of stuff and also
rebuild the skull she's a collagen
peptides a scuba the morning drinks with
evening drink she's the collagen
peptides
um let's see here uh I'll excuse me I
wonder also to have a synaptic of three
of those twice a day I do that
um it's two miles a month it's gonna
help with the brain cells talking to
each other brain cells talking to the
spinal cord spinal cord talks in the
brain cells and again don't forget that
I-26 says so important I I have people
who hate supplements but they love I-26
it comes in three ways of powder
capsules and chewable I like the chills
because they taste like vanilla ice
cream they're soft and chewy not not
crunchy Dusty things okay so uh and then
don't forget the rebound for the energy
or rebound we have the sticks we have
the canisters uh each dose of the sticks
there's 36 in a box there's 36 servings
of canister each serving and the cancer
are the six contains a hundred nutrients
including 75 minerals we do have the
cans but the cans do have carbonation
them so I recommend if you're going to
drink the cans which I do at home I take
the sticks and the cancer on the road
but at home I take the cans pop the tops
at night put them in the refrigerator so
in the morning
all the carbonation is gone so I drink
one with breakfast I'll have a half one
at lunch the second half of the second
one I'll drink during the afternoon so I
have energy all day
our rebound has 100 nutrients in it Red
Bull has one mineral magnesium
a lot of sugar a lot of caffeine
that's what drives their energy is sugar
and caffeine okay but they run out of
steam somewhere along the line okay and
bad things happen
and so that's why we came out with the
75 minerals in our sports drink we
actually made it for Theo Ratliff in the
beginning okay
and and so he came he came out he lost
his position we landed Hawks because he
had bone bone arthritis his knee is only
24. his hips his fractured his
um shooting arm wrists uh and um he was
he was the Top Shot blocker from one of
the top scorers
and um for the Atlanta Hawks and and
also for the entire NBA but they took
his contract away and kicked him out
because he had all these things falling
apart
we came up with a healthy Bone and Joint
pack for him and rebuilt him he came
back and played for another 11 years
made a hundred million dollars in
contract was that cool
so that's where this comes in we have so
many stories like that from so many
athletes including Theo Ratliff he has
the stories there's a female in here
um okay and she was a basketball player
she played professional basketball she
was All-American when she played in
college or university of Tennessee okay
and Kelly Herron is her name okay and
her picture is in here I'm with her and
I'm up to her armpits and
same way we'll see around if I'm up to
his armpits and then Championship boxers
like Evander Holyfield all these
politicians pastors so many great
pastors including uh let's see here Mike
Pastor Mike Freeman up in Baltimore
Maryland and then
let's see what's another big Pastor here
in this book here
there you go Pastor Creflo Dollar
he and I went around the world okay we
went all over the country he he
introduced me to the black community
okay pastor Chris little dollar so we're
just really so proud that this is all
happening and of course we have
politicians in here
um we have Scholars we have all kinds of
people yeah boom Pat Boone's in here
famous singer and actor
um Danny Glover man singer and actor and
comedian he's in here okay so it's not
like we're making this stuff up
so I hope that helps Chad it does she
also has a severe constipation that
she's had since she was a child
well she needs to be sure she's staying
away from all the bad stuff fried foods
processed Meats oils glutens we brought
around oats sugar carbonated drinks even
though that one's got to go uh bubbly
drinks got to go with carbonated water
and we do have uh let's see here we have
the ultimate enzymes we call the
gallbladder about it wouldn't hurt for
her to have one or two of those say five
or ten minutes for each meal a couple
ounces of water and
um let's see here anything else you'd
recommend
yeah I would recommend that one the
herbal rainforest but also our daily
daily digest packs
those are incredible when it comes to
digestive issues especially that like
constipation
digest ultimate daily Digest
and Dr Wallach for talking to an amazing
Pastor right now I'm sorry
Pastor Deborah Smith she's pretty
awesome doc she's part of our team
thank you thank you God bless you I know
he loves you yes he does yes thank you
all right
thank you and we have lots of hands
going up Dr Wallach so let's just jump
right over to TC TC go ahead and unmute
yourself if you'd like to come on camera
you don't have one so just go ahead and
talk do you see
foreign
okay talk loud I can barely hear you can
you hear me now yes sir okay uh hello
dog Joel yes sir we gotta go quick
yes we're towards the end of the program
you gotta go quick sir
okay uh first off I I've been taking uh
first off I'm 67 this weekend and uh I'm
150 pounds five foot nine
and um I've been taking Beyond Tangy
Tangerine for the last four years I've
taken immortalium for the year and a
half now uh the thing is I have a left
inguinal hernia which I got about six
and a half years ago and I have gray
hair and about a year later I got a
hemorrhoid
all right now I've had a few other
injuries that are minor I don't know if
you want me to go on or you want to ask
me because we only have a moment
okay so you're taking part of the recipe
if you have a cake recipe with 18
ingredients you only put four of the
ingredients in there you're gonna get
the best result no you're just taking
bits and pieces you're not taking the
entire thing okay instead of just taking
the Tangy Tangerine I want you to take
two healthy brain and heart packs per
month two health and heart pressure
months okay it's a big difference okay
and heart pack and just a tiny tangerine
okay and so take two how to bring 100
packs per month if all does everything
twice a day you need two bottles of
msm63 breakfast Street Laundry dinner
time you need the collagen peptides take
a scoop of that with bread coats and
scuba that with dinner drinks
um
you also need to get me one of those
belts that you wear with a hernia a big
pad on it that holds a inguinal hernia
in okay put your
um feet in such a position in your bed
you know put the two a four by four
underneath the
um feet of the beds so the hernia thing
is going away okay then taking the
pressure off the hernia site in your
inguinal area Okay and then we have the
Hair Skin and Nails take three of those
twice a day or take three three times a
day I take three twice a day I only
weigh 142 pounds and um again for the
hemorrhoids I'd also take the healthy
brain and heartbreak we already said
that
um and we need the oh the ultimate daily
classic tab is three words all the daily
classic tablets take three of those
twice a day that's going to support
healthy blood vessels red blood cells
white blood cells that's going to
support healthy arteries and veins blood
pressure all that kind of stuff and so
give us a call every couple of weeks if
you're on any kind of medications for
blood sugar for
um for blood pressure don't cold turkey
off of them but you're going to start
seeing I had white hair and so we came
up with the
um Hair Skin and nails and now even the
girls were saying today oh your hair is
all dark brown now or black or had been
white years ago okay that's not I'm not
dying my hair it's coming from taking
all these nutrients it's just telling me
that I'm giving my body what it needs
including the skin okay which is kind of
like a early warning signal so so with
that I'm going to turn this back over to
Becca I don't know if you have one more
we want to get to or
yes Janet is on high blood pressure
medicine she's 62 years old 5 foot 10
165 pounds
her feet have started to swell slightly
and healing is slowed significantly when
scratched cut or bruised also has an
aorta defect of dissection
[Music]
okay very nice section okay all right
and she weighs 150
65 pounds okay well she's giving her all
the bad foods no fried foods no
processed me some oils or gluten so we
brought around those so sugar no
carbonated drinks even the no buckwheat
no carbon or drinks you know the diet
one's got to go and the carbonated
water's got to go cheese too healthy
brain and heart patch a month to pull
those thing twice a day change two
bottles of MSM so you can take three
breakfast treat lunch for dinner time is
going to build all those cartilaginous
stuff rebuild that including the re
walls including aorta okay
um and because of the hybrid pressure I
wanted to have the ultimate daily
classic tapestry those
um you'll see she could go through three
three twice a day okay I do that and I
weigh 142. it'll be two hours a month
and here that's going to help her if
she's on high blood pressure medication
don't don't cold turkey off of it but
has the blood pressure drops you can
still reduce medication based on the
numbers uh let's see here
um she has
um let's see here oh okay she should
also take our rebound or sports drink
with 100 nutrients in it and um she can
have her body weight I take two doses a
day at 165 she could take two doses a
day no problem but if she takes the cans
she's gonna pop the tops on him the
night before she drinks them so that and
put them in the refrigerator so it'll be
flat in the morning all the bubbly will
be gone don't forget the ultimate
enzymes I do take those she needs the
ultimate enzymes to help her absorb all
this stuff okay
but then collagen
peptides the MSM is also going to help
her rebuild the artery because when you
have an and an artery defect whether
it's AR or pulmonary artery or arteries
in your leg or anything when you get
those artery defects is because you're
not getting enough of the connective
tissue maintenance materials which are
in okay which are in the MSM and the in
the um uh collagen peptides okay
all right thank you so much Dr Wallach
and
everybody if you were invited to this
program by somebody specific please make
sure that you get back with them ask
them how they prefer to get their
products because there are several
different ways to get products because
we are an army of health coaches people
that care about health and have decided
to build an income stream
around health and nutrition so make sure
that you get back with them if you have
never spoken to anybody about youngevity
or the products or Dr Wallach we invite
you to go to daily withdoc.com this is
our website where the daily with Doc
team are part of it and we have a store
there that lists all the products that
Dr Wallach is speaking of
we also have our sign up for our
newsletter sign up for our newsletter
get plugged in if you have a question
for Dr Wallach or about your health and
you would like to get some nutritional
suggestions
submit your your suggestions there on
that form to
sign up for our newsletter we will get
one of our certified holistic health
coaches to respond to you if we don't
know the answers we have direct
connections with Dr Wallach and many
times I'll bring those questions on here
on daily with Doc as well but we want to
make sure that you are getting the
information that you need as an
empowered individual to make those
informed choices that just make sense
folks our food has no nutrition
so if we eat eat because we feel like
we're hungry it's not because we're
hungry it's because our body is saying
hey
I need something more but it's not
calories that it's screaming for folks
it's the nutrition and that is where
youngevity and its formulas within the
product line
meet those deficiencies I can go
well I very seldom have any cravings and
I can go a long time without eating
because I'm not starving I eat because I
know I need the calories I need you know
it just makes sense
but when you crave all the time that
doesn't make sense
it's because your body is trying to tell
you something
it needs nutrition
so we invite you to try Dr wallach's
formulas as a solution to
not just
health and the problems that people have
going on with their health
but a solution to a food supply that is
null and void of what the body really
needs
so if I could get my co-hosts up with me
I'd greatly appreciate that because I
couldn't do this without them we thank
everybody that's out there on YouTube
everybody who has joined us through the
live stream we had quite a few viewers
today quite a few people in the chat
talking we had AJ out there as our as
our coach helping people and making sure
that I got their questions in front of
me so that I could see them as things
are scrolling through
we have
Marilyn here in the live Zoom with us
and retyping what Dr Wallach recommends
and putting it in that chat so that then
AJ
or Ruth Ellen can take that valuable
information and share it in YouTube as
well
um that we're just a team we all work
together and we have Ruth Ellen she's
she's like she's my production manager
she's my executive production manager
and helping make sure that everything
goes smoothly in the areas that she's
able to while I'm working with the
technical issues on this end but I
couldn't do it without these folks
we are a community we are a family we
are a team and folks if you're looking
for that type of environment where
people are working together
like-minded wanting to serve and be a
blessing to others as we are providing
Solutions
that folks if you take the
supplementation
and you give the body what it's needing
the body's absorbing
the cells are going to get healthier
the body will become healthier
it just makes sense so if you're wanting
to be part of something that just makes
sense whether you want to just try the
products or join us on this Crusade
please go to daily withdoc.com use that
contact option on the website or get
back with the person that shared this
program with you because we have open
arms
there's no pre-judging
if you have a heart for others or even
yourself and you just want to make
yourself your family healthy and then
those around you see hey they're getting
healthy what are they doing and they ask
you can actually get thank you checks
from youngevity for sharing your
recommendations you can't do that for
sharing the your favorite cologne
well unless it's one that youngevity
offers all it's going to say or your
shampoo unless it's one that youngevity
offers because you know both of those
are part of what I love and youngevity
offers them so
thank you again for joining us here on
daily with Doc my name is Becca dukes
and it is my honor and privilege to be
able to be a resource and provide this
information to you
feel free to join us next time Monday
through Friday daily with Doc zoom.com
from 12 to 12 50 ish Pacific time that
is on Zoom so make sure that you you can
join us from a computer a laptop a
mobile device anywhere that has
connection if you sign up for our
newsletter we even send you out
reminders that have a phone number that
you can call in little more difficult to
ask questions that way but we want to
make sure that we are meeting people
where they're at so that they too can be
included in this crusade to save
humanity and the world until next time
bye for now
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]